okay what up guys
welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel
today um i am going live
and i literally have no idea what i'm
gonna do live but
i'm gonna let the comments basically
like tell me if you guys want me to
react to something or
talk about something yeah so whatever
you guys really want to do
that's what i'm gonna do
oh wait let me turn the sound off so i
can see the chat
okay
let's see what i'm gonna try to do
also
i'm good what's up brianna what up
brianna
okay so i i'm trying to figure out what
i want to do
okay actually i have a topic that i want
to talk about really quick
um so i think that one thing that girls
in general don't understand the
difference between
is sexual attention and like wifey
attention
um for example actually let me go
and make sure i'm gonna put up an
example but
a lot of times girls will put up like
i'm just gonna google
it's gonna make my
my search history look weird um
okay instagram
okay here we go now this is what i mean
girls will put up pictures like this or
get like the hottest
um surgery the hottest whatever in order
to get like attention from men
and you know
honestly like guys will make it out to
be so bad but i think both genders in
like a perfect world would love
attention
from the opposite genders um
but the problem with this stuff is if
you present yourself like this
what type of men are going to be you
know
hitting you up if all you have on your
social media is just your body
and girls will like they'll think it's
good because they'll get like more dms
and maybe more like
likes whatever but um at the end of the
day
you're getting sexual attention not like
wifey attention so let me look up like
i'm just gonna google christian woman
and see what comes up
like this this looks like the type of
girl
oh my gosh i should make this bigger or
put this on the other side
okay how do i do this but this this
looks like the type of girl that you
would marry
right this looks like the type of girl
you take on a date
um i'm trying to make it like bigger but
okay i don't know how to do it but you
guys get what i'm saying right
and i just this is i see this mistake a
lot
you know it's not like either of these
girls are like super crazy hot and are
gonna get all the likes and all the
whatever but then you might get asked on
more dates than the first girl
what other topics do you guys want me to
talk about cause
i will
she looks like me kind of actually
i don't even try to we could do not a
redhead we could do a brunei
that too
um okay someone said nasty c sma
i'm a little nervous as to what that
means
oh this is a video
why would i say that men should date
actually i'd rather talk about this for
so why would i say that men should date
single mothers
um okay this is what i say when it comes
to that
if you're a guy you have to understand
your league
okay so actually i'm gonna pull up this
chart i think that let me pull it up on
my
computer um
slides
this no single mothers ever every person
has
a
okay this is what i meant let me pull it
up
now look i'm not saying you have to date
single mothers
if that's your pro if you don't want to
date single mothers i 100 get that
but this is what i'm saying
if you're in the chad level of looks
right oh wait shoot did i oh yeah i did
okay if you're in the chad level of
looks of course don't date a single mom
if you're slightly above average don't
date a single mom
if you're average don't date a single
mom
but if you're below average like it's
slim pickins
so i mean i'd love to tell you each and
every one of you guys is gonna get a
girl there's a girl out for every single
one of you
um but i just personally like don't
believe that so if you're
at the low end of the average scale or
the below average guy
you might have to like depending on what
options you have and when you want to
get married
you may have to like there might have to
be one or two things that have to give
in order to get
a girlfriend or wife sorry
um if you don't care about getting that
and don't want that fine
but it's either probably gonna be the
um the heavier girls with no kids which
is fine um
you know you can go that route could be
this the slightly above average single
mom with one kid
that's fine um
or shoot for the stars guys if you can
find
for the average and below average guys
if you can find a pretty
girl with no kids go for it
you know do what you want and that also
is mentally stable
go for it taking care of another man's
child no
yeah i mean ideally she would have no
kids i'm with you
not but not everyone has that option
like i'm gonna get i'm gonna give you an
example
um
my sister my older sister she's a very
loyal person
she's very hard-working um and she's a
good wife honestly
and she makes six figures and she had
two kids he married another guy
that had one kid he also made six
figures and
i think he was maybe five years older
than her
but that blended family worked out does
it work out a hundred percent of the
time
no and if you're given the option
between a girl with no kids and a girl
with kids
cool pick that but i'm just being real
and none of the other dating coaches are
real with you guys
if you're short it's gonna be tough
okay so adjustables and this is just
what i think if you're an average guy
and i'm not talking about extremes right
there's
obviously going to be extremes like jeff
bezos is an extreme bill gates is an
extreme
they're going to be able to like change
two levels like
mark zuckerberg average guy probably
could get a model and get in the model
level just because of his income but
most
people in general
they're not going to be able to to move
too um
they're not going to be able to move two
lanes like you can probably just get up
slightly above what you are
sorry i'm just the only dating i'm the
only date person the manosphere
that's going to tell you that but yeah
these are the adjustables so
fitness get your fitness up you can go
from average to slightly above average
income same thing
game being funny and this is the common
interest i don't think people talk about
enough
there are some times when you meet
someone and you just have that really
strong connection
and that like you guys are the same type
of person you just get along
easy where when people have enough
common interest men and women i've seen
it both ways
they'll overlook you know them being a
little overweight or not exactly their
type or whatever
whatever but they have um
okay no single mother's effort that's
totally fine
if you're short go to asia and find a
wife see this that's an extreme
that's the thing are most
average guys going to go to asia to find
a wife
no so let's talk about the normal
like what the average nine to five guy
is going to do
um okay is he going to move to asia or
go on a trip to asia for two weeks and
be able to pick a wife in that two weeks
probably not um okay
but yeah um fitness income game
being funny common interest but look at
this guy here
i really don't see him being able to
get to slightly above average unless
he really focused in on every single
thing
and i'm sorry but most people in general
don't most people if they work hard and
do the right things they can get from
below average to average or average to
slightly above average just depending
how you're born and like quite honestly
i've never seen a guy without
absolutely has a no game at all big have
like take a course and then all of a
sudden have game
you know i'm it's rare i'm sure it
happens but
that dude probably spent an incredible
amount of hours doing that
um okay so we can go to the women sorry
um
yeah and i think women it's the same
thing so like women are born with the
face they're born with and they either
go down
or up depending on how feminine they are
their body and how friendly they are
and then like let's say a guy is a model
level
and he meets a girl that's a six to
seven but he finds out that they're
compatible and
have common interests whatever he might
overlook the fact that she's
a little less good-looking or you know
it just depends on the person what they
value but what
bothers me is like dating coaches act
like you can go from
being a sub five
to a model and i just genuinely don't
think that's true and a lot of these
ideas came from the account wheat
waffles which you guys should totally go
subscribe to
because
okay sorry
your kevin samuel segment is great your
instagram is great thank you
also if you guys like
the the stream feel free to send a
donation because
i'm trying to i'm trying to buy some
travel gear
the for four girl pick is brutal
that's like a point zero this girl
i give her like a four honestly maybe
i don't know i mean everyone it doesn't
really matter what i think to be honest
whatever whatever your scale is
okay what else do you guys want to talk
about or do you want to see me react to
i can do a lot of stuff
but people always talk in the extremes
like this is what bothers me about the
man of sphere
people always talk in the extremes this
is what they do
they'll say oh don't ever date a single
mother
and yeah i'd say in the perfect world
but
guys you have to understand like
sometimes you're going to meet a girl
that doesn't give you everything you
want
and you just get along and like it just
happens and i've heard a million people
like both men and women say that
oh the girl in the first one oh no she
is a 0.1
oh my god totally i said four or below
so like she's in the or below
taking care of another man's child isn't
extreme
true true
but a lot of guys do it
a lot of guys do it sorry
single moms are for 40 year old versions
not completely true not completely
true it used to be considered an extreme
well and the other thing guys you have
to realize people like
people that are like them so that's why
a lot of guys with kids will date a girl
with kids because
they can relate would you prefer a woman
with no kids
sure but like a guy making 60 70 000
that already has two kids
or one kid would he take on one more
especially if the woman like can take
care of them herself and already has the
money
some guys would you know okay let's see
oh wait um okay three types of men and a
woman's heart the bad boy the pretty boy
and the guy that are neither of those
basically the nice guy and everything
else is at the bottom of the barrel
in terms of choice
[Music]
i don't necessarily think that's true
compared to other video online let's see
can i get the mic to go
is this audio better let me know
um i just turned it up so we'll see if
that helps
sorry and the the sound is definitely
coming from my
ac unit but maybe if i put the
thing on
there's levels to single moms in most
scenarios guys
are thinking of the ones with multiple
kids
by different dads who are still alive
yeah no
i mean for sure that's
a hundred percent a real thing like
and i know that's that's the thing like
when
on these shows we are always thinking
about the extreme like the extremely
ratchet girls or the extreme
girls that are
you know super out there but guys i got
no dog in this fight i do not have kids
out of wedlock
like i'm not pregnant none of that so
it doesn't really matter to me i'm just
genuinely saying what i've seen in the
world
and i i wonder if there's like
statistics
on um
percentage of single mothers
get married
okay
let's see
15 eye-opening stats for single mom
numbers on single parents
suggest they're okay when it comes to
single mothers stats
indicate that 40 of them are currently
divorced or separated okay
29 of single mothers and their children
are living on
poverty uh let's see
um
okay in cases
with children okay i just want to see
i wish i could see what
percent of single mothers remarry and
i'm sure it's significantly lower than
people without kids
but i just feel like online we always
think at the extreme and i just think of
people i've seen in my life
okay um
have i ever watched strong successful
male
no i have not but let me
okay let's go to his channel
and look up the one of the most popular
videos
soldier gets even for cheating on wife
this one's only seven minutes
all right guys welcome back to strong
successful mail so
today i'm gonna be going over an article
written by a woman
where she's basically complaining and
pointing out how men
are now overreacting to the fact that
because of the metoo movement
we're now starting to avoid women in the
workplace and so forth
and a lot of our actions are showing how
we can and she claims that
they're basically being punished because
of me too
so i'm going to go this article here
lots of very interesting stuff that none
of you will be surprised about because
of how things have been going lately
and the title of the article is men now
avoid women at work
another sign we're being punished for me
too
and goes on to say here the beginning of
the article
a new study is found u.s men appear to
be following mike pence's lead
maybe they're angry that me too ever
happened
an article says here it looks like mike
pence is quite the trendsetter
the u.s vice president famously refuses
to have dinner alone
with any woman who isn't his wife and
now working men across corporate america
appear to be following his lead
i think that is a good idea for guys
that makes sense
especially if you're married don't put
yourself in a situation where someone
can accuse you of something don't do it
don't do it yeah they're doing it to
protect our asses
says
hang on a second here guys it says a new
study
due to be published in the journal
organizational dynamics
has found that following the metoo
movement men are significantly more
reluctant
to interact with their female colleagues
a few highlights from the research
include
27 percent of men avoid one-on-one
meetings with female co-workers
yep that's right almost a third of men
are terrified to be alone
in a room with a woman well yeah
considering how things have been going
and how
pretty much you're guilty until proven
innocent god forbid there's an
accusation about something
even simply as an overreaction
it says you're 21 of men so they would
be reluctant to hire a woman for a job
they require close interaction such as
business travel
19 of men will be reluctant to hire an
attractive woman
the data above was collected in early
2019 from workers across a wide range of
industries
researchers had asked the same questions
in early 2018 just as me too was in full
swing
and depressingly things appear to have
gotten worse
in 2018 for example 15 percent of men
said they'd be more reluctant to hire
women for jobs
that require close interpersonal
interactions with women compared to 21
in 2019 yeah i mean
that's just the direction things have
gone i mean
don't blame us men are covering their
asses because they can
okay this seems like an interesting
video
i have no complaints i could understand
why that would be
honestly
um that's the thing i don't know why
sometimes people think i'm like
a feminist on this channel
and i'm just chilling you know what i
mean i just i really just chill
let's see what i want to react to next
coach greg adams
looks like i've searched him before
oh i've reacted to taylor the fiend
before oh i've seen this guy actually
let's look at one of his more popular
videos
one of my mentors once told me this when
i was about 18 years old he told me
never move in with the woman
and he meant never move into her
domicile never moved into her
residence into her apartment into her
house
because that place will never be yours
all right any conflict
anytime you need to get something
resolved she will make it be known that
it is her
place it will never put you in a proper
perspective as a man
it will never put you in the proper
authority and you will never build
enough value
for her to respect you as a man
nothing lower than a man that lives off
a woman all right that's not how things
are ordered all right and we're not
living in order we're living in chaos
and chaotic times are when men move in
with women
okay i can see that let's see what else
um
what's going on everybody it is coach
greg adams back in here with another
video
shout out to the coach game for being
here being involved and being active
in these comment sections check out the
free agent lifestyle book where you get
a chance it is available on amazon
let's kick this topic real quick this is
a common
response that i hear from women out
there on the field or women that i meet
or women that see me on social media and
all of these things maybe on the youtube
channel they may come on here
and they'll see the lifestyle that i
live they see the freedom that i have
they see the joy that i have in raising
my children
they see the trips that i take and
travel to they see all of the things
that i enjoy
in my life and the question that they
often come to or ask me is that they'll
say this they'll say
honestly i don't understand why you're
still
single i mean how is nobody able to snap
you
up why are you still single and to them
what they see is me having enjoyment me
having resources
and they're wondering why it is
in their mind why is it so difficult for
me to find a woman
now i'm gonna break down this basic
question
okay because what you have to understand
is
my goals all right i'm very
goal-oriented and i'm very
responsible of where i spend my time all
right
i don't like to waste time some people
don't like to waste money i don't like
to waste
time more than i don't like to waste
money okay all right when i feel like my
time is being raped or my time is being
taken advantage of or not being
considered
i take it very personally because i have
a lot of things that i could comp
accomplish in a day and if someone
flakes or somebody's taking more time in
my life than i really need them
to i really get you know flustered all
right i get frustrated
with that so when i do that i really
protect my time
i'm really doing that for a purpose it's
very intentional
and women typically try to take
advantage of your time especially if
they can reel you in emotionally
if you're dating them they feel like
they're entitled to certain time they
feel like if you
have free time then that should be time
that you should be dedicating to them
they feel like there should be a certain
response time to text messages
and they feel like they should be
entitled to certain details about your
life
for me i don't feel like that that they
deserve that entitlement all right
you don't need to get an immediate
response from me because you don't play
that big of a
important role in my life now
with that i have certain goals that i'm
trying to attain and i know
that if being in a relationship many
times women will sabotage your goals
for their own personal gratification all
right
just because you're okay there's an
observation of men
[Music]
that teach dating advice a lot of them
remain
single to an old age
and most men want to have kids in their
40s and 50s
it seems like and you guys can correct
me if i'm wrong most men
ideally would like to have kids with the
same woman stay married to the same
woman
maybe f around in their 20s whatever but
like
35 start having kids
maybe 40. um but because guys you have
to realize having kids later in life
like
it comes with repercussions my dad
they didn't have kids later in life they
just kept having kids because i have
nine siblings
he's in his 50s and my little sister is
still in the house my parents have been
dying
for us to be out of the house for like
10 years
i don't know i i can't say
wow i wish i'd trade places with them
like that sounds like a great life
even even if they're high value and they
have the option to date a lot of women
a lot of women is that really gonna
bring them fulfillment
i don't know it might you're spending
time
and being an emotional tampon for them
they feel like
they're getting what they need despite
the fact that you're not reaching your
goals despite the fact that you're not
where you want to be in your life
they don't care about that they only
care about the now
well for men who have vision which is
one of our greatest gifts
we have the ability to look years into
the future and realize that what i'm
doing today
matters years from now women don't have
that ability
they only think about what they happens
today
and they face the repercussions of it
three years later and they're in total
shock
not realizing that they made the reason
why they're in the place they're in
three years ago is because of decisions
they made today
all right now in terms of taking the red
pill once you take the red pill and
understand these things about women all
right
and their nature it's not some of the
things that they do intentionally
these are things that they do do
unknowingly um
they don't they don't even realize that
they're doing it and
when you bring them into your layer when
you bring them into your life
they become a major distraction okay i'm
reading one of the comments emotional
tampon
listen up pearly your fellow gender just
waits and finishes
and at the finish line for the winners
okay
i'm going to correct you the women that
are interested in you
wait at the finish line for the winners
gosh i mean oh guys i'm thinking about
the girls i played volleyball and
basketball with
a lot of them have gotten married the
last couple years to guys that are their
age
that might be the issue in the circles
like you're in but
change your circle that's really not
always the case
and i don't this is just i'm just going
off intuition i'm just going off
what i've seen um so i could be wrong
i'd really be interested in seeing like
date more data on that
but let me let me look up the average
age gap
in average age gap
in marriages
because i would imagine income is
associated with age
um what's the average age difference
in a couple
um how do i see
okay
so the average age gap
for male female which is the red one
oh so this is based on their age so two
years
so even even at 48 the average age gap
in a marriage is five years
you guys are talking about the hottest
girls
okay um your friends aren't the majority
well then
why is the average age gap only
around five um
let's see
unless a marriage is 10 plus years old
it's not even worth considering since
most end at seven years or earlier
okay let's let's google average
age gap in 20-year
marriages have a feeling
um
look at this guys 20-year age gap more
likely to divorce
so it seems like the less the age gap
the more likely that the divorce or that
they stay married
am i just you could it sounds like i'm
disproving your point you can
i could be wrong you know feel free to
let me know
in the comments but if if if the
hypothesis
is that women just wait at the finish
line right
and the finish line is like women tend
to date older
and they want a man that's established
in his career
okay why why isn't the age gap bigger
because that would mean that the models
the hottest girls the hottest youngest
chicks
are dating the oldest guys
okay let's see the comments um
okay uh men have kids
in their 30s and 40s
um it's not about older man it's about
finishing the race
okay i want to say average age
i'm gonna google the average age
men and women have
kids
um
the average woman has her first baby at
31.
huh that's older than i thought actually
so and then if the average man like ten
if the average age gap in marriages
is between two to seven years that means
the guy okay so thirties to forties
that's right
um both genders
are frustrated and traumatized by the
top 10 of the opposite gender
yeah and this is what i say god okay
guys will go all day about girls
hypergamy right girls
but here's the thing girls and guys want
the best possible person to date
and that's all hypergamy is as both as
women looking for the best possible
women
or a man to date and men do the exact
same thing
you know men want the most fit feminine
and friendly
girl they can date
um
let's see
all right there's a post on reddit where
people want to be every red pill
argument with stats and all of that if
that's true
send it to me on instagram
and i will
even look at it right now okay
well hypergamy i don't really like that
word because all it's saying is women
want the best possible mate
so do men most men just don't have that
many options if most men
had the option to date a model that was
super fit feminine and friendly
most men would date her sorry
like um
the age gap isn't bigger because highly
successful men only make up 10 to 15
of men when you date on your level you
tend to pick your age range
yeah okay fair enough um
you're wrong hypergamy has much more to
do with resources and social status
i never said it had nothing to do with
resources and
social status i said that it starts with
looks
guys have a look they have a face and a
height
so if a guy's average height is six five
i put that in the top
like as a ten right his face is a five
you divide that
you average that out that makes him a
seven point five
um if he's awkward he goes down if he's
interesting right if he's charismatic he
goes up and then like that
adjusts you based on the level that you
start at
um okay
let's see i know three
average looking guys making under 50k
under age 26 married
married to employed nice looking girls
their own age last year even if they're
outliers why i was fired of mediocrity
don't i don't care what you do
um a lot of women are delusional
100 but sometimes i think you guys are
delusional too
that watch the channel because you guys
will say oh i want a lady
that doesn't have a that has a low body
count i'll have a woman
that doesn't have a kid i'll have a
woman that
is fit like f and and feminine
and friendly i would never date that
then that but
my if you're an average guy you might
have to
if you can become a high value man and
that's in the cards for you great but
it's a small percentage
it's not most of you um
okay pearly men were surveyed if they
had women with 80
of what they wanted the majority would
jump on it woman refused and would never
settle
um
let's see pearly menswear okay
um the question i have is men were
surveyed if you send me that topic
let me know because i would totally read
that but
the question is this is my problem with
um a lot of
a lot of the the surveys and stuff that
document like
mating and dating preferences and say
that men aren't picky men aren't picky
men are picky
okay if you survey a man would he go on
a second date with a girl
he would say yeah because guys are
looking for sex but
women are looking at that guy is he a
husband from the first date
more more than not so that's why they
filter out guys faster
but guys will hook up with a girl that
they have no intention of marrying so
the only way i would
i would find that study credible is if
they said
if you found a woman that had 80 of what
you wanted would you marry her
so that's that's what i would say
because that's the only way you can
measure it you can't measure it
would a man go on a second date with a
woman would a woman go on a second date
with a man
because they're looking for completely
different things in large
okay a woman wants a six foot tall and
six figures and a guy wants a woman
who's nice and gives him sex there's a
difference
um that's not necessarily true they also
want a woman that they're attracted to
and if you're born an unattractive woman
you can't really change that
um same with the height thing that just
sucks
um
okay are delusional men are the minority
of society because
society holds us up to account in other
aspects of life
no one is allowed to deny a woman um
i think women get denied more than you
think and are rejected more than you
think
the way that a woman is rejected is she
is rejected for a relationship women are
not rejected for sex but women are
rejected for relationships constantly
[Music]
um
the number of average guys not dealing
with women is rising
okay fair enough um
some women do finesse men i'm not saying
that doesn't happen
women waste more time
on dates than men 40 percent of women
just want
food on a date okay this is how i see
women just wanting food on a date i
think a lot of girls say that and don't
actually mean it
a lot of girls i think are very
frustrated by going in date after date
after date and not really finding a guy
that they connected with right
so they just say oh i'm just going for
the food to kind of like
soften the blow of i can't get a date
with someone that i actually like like
um this is just my like interpretation
as a girl of that
i think girls are always open to the
possibility that if they go on a date
with someone
it could possibly lead to something but
they're just more picky and are gonna
swipe guys away um but you know that
could be a real thing that's just
how i see it um
ryan thank you for the donation um
patrice
o'neil let's let's google it
god um
really don't
let's see is this a long oh
no 14 minutes
[Applause]
no this is only six
okay
um what's uh uh the difference between
what's wrong with men what's wrong with
women is that you point out
what's wrong with men everyone claps the
reverse is demonized
a hundred percent i agree with you i
don't think it's cool
to say men are trash i don't think it's
cool the same men are the problem
i think people are the problem and
people will be people so
[Music]
um
okay the game compliance versus and men
are looking to get as much of a woman's
compliance before giving investment
and women are looking to get a man's
investment before giving compliance
uh what do you mean by compliance but
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna watch this
video and then i'll
respond in a second
so next up on the chopping block xm
satellite radio djs opie and
anthony they're under fire now for
airing joking comments about
raping secretary of state condoleezza
rice will they
be the next to go is radio cleaning
house
after the imus debacle with me now new
city president
now new city for president sonia osario
she took part in a recent protest
calling for radio stations to
stop supporting negative language in
music and talk radio and also
our favorite stand-up comic patrice
o'neill
thank you sir patrice uh are on a next
i hope not i hope jv i wish jv and i was
gonna lose their job or imus it's funny
this is the thing i i have i don't know
her but i'm
i'm assuming that she has nothing to do
with funny
so i'ma speak as the expert on funny
funny people should just be left to
trying to be funny
what if they're not funny then you made
a mistake but how many
listen how many times has the unfunny
how many
unfunny rape jokes lead to rape like i
don't know how many jokes about rape
there are there's a lot
but you your world is not funny your
world is
next on the big story my world is
people trying to be funny well i mean
you think it's okay to try to make jokes
about rape
i'm diabetic i make fun of that i'm a
victim
i might lose a toe but i'm trying to
make fun of i'm trying to make fun of
anything i
i think i can make fun of sonia
you know what's happening now is the
marketplace
okay is deciding what's
appropriate or what's not appropriate is
i think the nation is just tired there's
a new
mood in the nation what nation the
nation you know what we're tired of
things that are
just a nation that's people in you i'm
not the nation i'm just speaking for me
and funny you're speaking for the nation
or are you speaking for
yeah you know why because i remember six
years ago
doing uh something against anthony
opening because they were just
so outrageous and their violent images
that they put out to women was just
uncalled for and now now i think people
do you think they were trying to be
funny
i think now people do you think they
were trying to be
tired you know what i don't care if
they're trying to be funny that's what
i'm saying
why are you in that business i've been
to your show once and it wasn't very
funny
being a woman it was hilarious when you
talked about that's why she doesn't like
me i was in the paper with her
and the joke is hilarious called the
angry pirate and the lady who wrote it
in
in her outrage didn't even know what it
meant and anybody who read it
laugh because they know what funny
you're not living in the context of
funny you're literally
the context of fire have every right to
be as funny as they want
they can go out and try to be as funny
as they want make as much money
make as much money being as funny as
they want this is what's happening
there is a change in this country people
are realizing they have an opportunity
to speak out
and advertisers are listening you're not
talking
about you're not talking to who i talked
and you're not going to get paid as much
money anymore tony and patrice look at
this the marketplace
more cbs radio firings they've been on
they've been on a tear lately
are they cleaning house or is this the
pc cops running off
you know what it is john you know what
it is while you're reading that paper
it's the pc cops
run a mug where you think she's a piece
of guy of course she is she's
she has an entire encyclopedia of of her
stance on it but it's no passion
involved it's not a real
this is just what she has to say we are
outraged and fired
and fired and fired main calling i'm
outraged
i am outraged you should be i am a fool
now if i called you a fool ah you know
what
people are feeling a new sense of
entitlement oh my god this lady's so
annoying
i'm too laid back i just don't care i do
not care what people do
in this country so here's what here's my
question
how can you justify a bad joke a joke
that isn't funny
wait a minute wait an attempt that isn't
funny
doesn't get any laughs and is about
raping
a the first black woman to ever become
the secretary of state of the united
states throw
is what i'm trying to fight for the joke
may or may
funny jokes and unfunny jokes are come
out of the same
birth that you you don't know if
anything is going to be funny
you should attempt to be able to make
anything you think a joke about
rape is doomed to be not funny it's
possible
but i've heard him i've heard you've
heard a funny rape joke
let's say a couple watch my hbo special
he's pretty good at it
yeah patrice patrice says that if you're
having sex with a woman
doggy style and if you wrong hit her in
the hit her in the head just the right
it's ejaculate in her eye and kick her
in the shin and she walks around like
that's what she was trying to say a
violent act of hitting her in the back
of her head her body it's called the
donkey punch which will then
why are you laughing she's outraged it's
called the donkey punch
it's all humor that she has no clue what
it is
the same problem that opium anthony does
you can't say just
anything on the air you can say anything
you want it might not be funny you might
get in trouble for it but you should
be able to be attempting and plus when
is a crazy
bum gonna get an opportunity to rate the
president if the president's wife john
he was trying to be funny all right
patrice why aren't i hearing al sharpton
complain about this thing
involving young uh black women well it's
evolving a very prominent black woman
well where was she doing during young
black everybody has their agenda
i was there i'm sorry yeah right excuse
me but why am i not hearing from
sharpton
because it doesn't concern him it's not
concerning ms black is
you know come on now you know al had al
sharpton has his agenda
and it was perfect for al young black
women
and now she's representing just women in
general she's not representing nappy
hope
she's representing the just the whole
the nappy headed part she has nothing to
do with
just a hoe sonia you know what
women have been abused publicly in the
media
for too long and people are tired of it
this has been a
beautiful response of just the general
public
saying to advertisers we're your
consumers
we don't want to have to avoid
everything in the street we don't want
to have to worry about what radio
station we turn on
and there is some really derogatory
violent you're going to deal with an
infamous
from someone making you uh aware that
someone may have said something that you
should be upset about
it's a shame your constituency the
people you represent aren't all victims
teresa o'neil thank you very much sonia
thanks for both be appreciated
time for big this is what you have to
deal with guys
i know but this is the at the end of the
day
it doesn't matter who you are
there are always going to be people with
a stick up their ass
there just is i'm the funnest person
ever
i've been doing like jokes and like fun
[ __ ]
since i was a kid one time when i was a
kid my mom
threw a school party right so it was
like
like every year there'd be like an end
of the year party and the parents would
like
organize it and do whatever
and the other moms they complained
and my mom got banned from throwing
school parties because it was too much
fun
some people just can't do they're so
miserable they can't deal with a big
ball fun
and i get it because i am a big big ball
of fun
i'm not even gonna lie to you
so you don't want to be
by king von i really wasn't going to do
rap music on this live
but i will no actually no it's going to
get demonetized
so i will not but
if you dm me the video on instagram just
probably things with the z
i will then
i will then do it pretty much
um i'll do it for like a video but not
for this
um
donovan sharp did i already look him up
let's see who this is
oh i think i've seen him
oh oh dear
that's like a 50 minute video
oh my god 30 minutes guys i need
remove from the partner program 10
minutes okay i've actually heard
from the women either directly or
indirectly who have been at the center
of these things
and it's been pretty much unanimous you
know what i needed to hear that
[Music]
that's right that's right it's your boy
kevin samuels what's going on kevin
dumb don't go what's going on guys how
are we doing tonight
what up what up what's up kevin good
good good good
thanks for having me on for a second
absolutely man uh listen man the the
kitchen is still
hot after you after you cooked what's
your face what's
the aftermath been like uh it's been uh
well personally it's been pretty good i
will say that uh
you know a lot of my critics and
detractors tend to think well you only
go after
black women you know and that shows the
fact
that i keep the same kind of talking
points for
anybody who wants to challenge what
we're saying over here
um i think it's been very well received
and i honestly think it's gonna
i think it's gonna change the
conversation for the next 90 days
honestly
why do you think because i think that i
think black women know
or at least i would think that they
would know that you don't
just like you treat everybody fairly and
it was clear that
that faithful was it wednesday or
thursday night you kept that same energy
the talking points were the same the
energies
the energy were the same do you think
that the quote-unquote black community
is going to give kevin samuel okay
listen man he goes after black women
guess what he treats the white girls the
same way too
or are they gonna are they just gonna
say well this is just a one-off they can
say what they want to but the work it
shows itself
see that's the problem many of these
folks who are my detractors are trying
to find
all kind of things that have a hint of
truth but
if you just do a little bit of watching
yourself
you'll see the truth and that's where
we're kind of at right now i think
that's a great lead into the broadcast
yeah
look extremes on either side are
extremes that i don't want to deal with
it's the people in the middle who are at
least willing to have the conversation
about the subject then where can we go
that's what i think is going to happen
now
what i think happened was because i'm on
another platform i'm talking to a group
of people who i really don't have any
you know uh prem issue it's this western
feminist womanist we don't need men
that's creeped into western civilization
that's rotting us from the inside
it's good that you treated her exactly
the same way and guess what kevin she
reacted
exactly the same way yeah
it was funny because deb was like uh did
myron go and and talk her back onto the
studio i said no meyer didn't chase her
down he was she
was talking to chris about something
giving a [ __ ] about her [ __ ] that
back i sweet talked her back to come
back on oh you didn't come back
yeah he did and by the way kevin she
says she would do a one-on-one with you
after the show she's like you know what
yeah i need his guidance after the show
she said that see that's ultimately
that's also kind of what i want to get
to we all have opinions and
and you know we get a chance to sharpen
our steel with each other
right but oftentimes women don't have a
chance to really no because women don't
tell each other the truth
even hear these kind of things much less
be challenged on them
because most folks would kind of demure
or go away
so it's a it's an unfamiliar experience
with a lot of women like
you'll be amazed some of my most viral
moments i've actually heard
from the women either directly or
indirectly who have been at the center
of these things
and it's been pretty much unanimous you
know what i needed to hear that
right right and that's where and that's
and that's the outcome i mostly
think we're ultimately going for i don't
care if people like me or dislike me
they don't know me
the people on this panel who actually i
speak too regularly who know me
that's who i care about whether or not i
care about those people's opinions
everybody else
cool but keep it to yourself because i
do like to carry
but i just want you to know that like it
amazes me
how when guys tend to go in a certain
direction with content
these glitches happen i mean my
instagram channel in the middle of a
live stream
was just accidentally deleted by
instagram what
yeah they said sorry about that we
didn't mean to do that
and i had to uh i had to upload the
message
peop that youtube sent me and then they
hear auburn preach who keep it pretty
clean
to hear that they have that their
channel has been
effectively removed from the partner
program so that means
all revenue super chat everything else
just almighty
and kevin you said they listen they keep
it super clean but i'm gonna tell you
what we've all watched i don't know if
they've i don't know if the panel has
watched the video
you've watched the video and i've
watched the video and they kept it super
clean
language wise but they did not and they
even say in the video hey man if you
speak a certain way
you're going to get uh you know you're
going to get community strikes deep
platform there's no stuff like this
and i remember thinking while i was
watching the video today it's amazing
that these guys are still
on youtube and they are still on youtube
but they have been quote unquote
removed from the partner program kevin
listen that's no coincidence man the
reason they've been removed from the
partner program
is because they're too big a channel to
be talking about what they're talking
about that's what it comes down to
well i think jordan peterson was the
first person
everybody needs to kind of study when he
made his
stance known about canada's ruling on
the pronoun usage
regarding the quote-unquote alphabet
community
jordan peterson says for the next two
years
he had to endure if you guys think what
i've been un
going on is something what that man had
to endure was even worse
two years of he said scandal after
scandal after this
after that this is before going online
with the interview with kathy newman
where went mega viral
before going on with the uh the uh
journalists on gq
but this is kind of the rite of passage
because
he was more or less a tip of the spear
on the online world
but if anybody on this side of the table
you know who's been doing this content
for the longest you know right
tom lycus was the forerunner all this
stuff but what i'm ultimately saying is
this
usually it's one person so it's easier
to get rid of one person but now it
seems to be
it's becoming i walk around and these
are the things that
may have been considered uh
taboo to talk about are being talked
about at chick-fil-a
wow these things are when i'm when i
walk and i see
and they're not just when i'm here
looking at
non-black people saying things that we
say on this side openly when i told you
when i went to l.a yeah
and i had you know people taking
photographs i mean i thought they were
looking at someone else no they were
looking at us
i've people men in that video when they
when auburn preach said this
is needed for the conversation because
ultimately what it starts to bring
is balance and i'm going to juxtapose
that with what happened on
on the fresh and fit podcast the other
day that conversation
after two days of having a back and
forth and even
earlier that day going up guys i
i don't deny that censorship is a thing
it's a hundred percent a thing
um yeah so you don't have to convince me
one direction it got a little bit more
balanced
when we could just vet ideas right
so and that's what we need to get to
because no one can tell me that this
country or the
in the western the west that we may be
doing okay from a financial standpoint
but from a
societal relational standpoint this
gender
uh war is making the
making all the western powers weak yes
yes and make no mistake it is absolutely
a gender war a lot of people like to say
well
men and women get along just fine no men
and women are not
getting along just fine and listen what
happened what happened
at the uh on the freshman fit podcast
after party
i think and that like kevin that was
like two worlds colliding you got this
pretty
dude you got this pretty white girl
freshly hit the wall she's entitled
she's got party voice i'm a half a man
and you absolutely and you and you
cooked her medium rare flipped her over
did it
did it for another 20 seconds it was the
thing of beauty well and the fact that
you know it was done with i of course
you guys know me i don't curse
i don't go there you know there were
plenty of times where
different racial sensitivities could
have been brought into the conversation
but they were not needed
you don't need we don't have to we we
have the facts data statistics and
actually the sense of
right and wrong is more on this side i
got to say one thing and i'm kind of
leaning back over to the platform
uh if you guys study anchor rome there's
a there's a premise that
part of the reason that uh rome fell
outside of the things we've been taught
over expansion in the west things like
this a part of the reason they think
a lot of these powers uh dwindle males
have long term thinking and girls just
want to have fun
in general if people are given the
opportunity to have fun and have it easy
they tend to pick that
if men at a young age were given the
option
to sleep with a bunch of same models and
live that life they probably
would most women that's what they choose
who was because of what i'm about to say
okay there was a writer called cato
that's why it's tough when you try to
come here from the woman's point of view
all we hear is the woman's point of view
it's
everywhere let the men have the
manosphere okay
guys i don't hold a gun dear how to make
you watch my channel
you can have a man of sphere
and as long as people watch my videos
i'll keep doing
stuff with it
okay like genuinely he said all
man all mankind controls its women
we control all mankind our women rule us
wow that's what he wrote about world the
how am i doing
i'm good guys i'm hella good all mankind
rules it's women we
rule all mankind meaning rome but in
rome our women rule
us and that was
and within a within about 150 years rome
had fallen yep yep get thousands of
hours of content not found anything
you're waiting for the new puppy i i
have a dog i don't
i don't need a new puppy what are you
talking about
your assumption is false because that's
not
that is not how it is women have always
been privileged my assumption about what
i believe in female privilege
there's no
i oh you know i definitely believe that
female privilege is real so
did they did you hear they're trying to
kick kevin samuels off of youtube
um they have a petition
um yeah that's wrong but at least
they appreciated and deferred to us so
we did all the sacrifice what reasons do
we have to support you
you don't have to support me you can't
you know i'm just trying to learn it's
been interesting
learning different stuff from the man's
point of view so genuinely on my channel
i'm not selling anything on my channel
like i probably will
at some point but in all honesty
i just watch videos that i find
interesting i think videos
from the man's point of view are
interesting
um
that's true i'm red pill but i'm weak
around woman with a big booty okay i
don't know how to feel about that
um however however bad
in any respect women think they had men
have always
had it worse some men
in all honesty if we go back to this
chart
i think that dating is easier
for an average is for an average woman
because i think an average guy
has more ability to like move up and
down
where an average woman has less ability
but you know
my two cents don't doesn't really matter
um did i ever go through a period
where i wished i was shorter a lot of
tall women i met wish
they were shorter for some reason
no um i wanted to be six one actually
so i'm six foot and i always wanted to
be six one because for volleyball that's
the perfect height for my that's like
the perfect height to go d1
six foot is just a slightly short
please react to dip by young chris
um no i'm not doing music videos in this
live
you know what's interesting though there
aren't a lot of women
that think like me in all honesty
because
how do i put this i have a hard time i
i can make female friends easily and i
always enjoy hanging around them like
they're high energy they're fun whatever
but i never agree with their beliefs
like my closest friends we don't agree
on anything they do not agree with this
stuff
rebecca bartlett oh i think i've seen
her
i actually think i'm have a collab
coming up with her soon
that's the like wife reacts account
right
i wonder where it is
okay but i'm gonna end this live because
i'm getting kind of tired
um if you have anything you want me to
react to just send it to my instagram
just probably things with a z
um because
that's what i do i go to my instagram
and like look at videos people have
requested
me to react to and i just picked some
don't forget to subscribe the channel
and bring the notification
bell and i'll talk to you guys next time